[Music]
in an existing GCP project click the
cloud shell icon in the blue menu bar at
the top to show the cloud shell frame at
the bottom of your window type in
g-cloud projects list choose one of your
projects to use for this QuickStart and
note the project ID type g-cloud config
set project followed by your project ID
next get the code for the sample app
engine app from github using the link
included in the QuickStart now go into
the newly created directory and deploy
this app with g-cloud app deploy you now
have an app engine app running and you
can check it in your browser to see that
it's working after your authenticate it
greets you by name perfect next you'll
add identity where proxy in front of
this app go to the navigation menu to
security to identity where proxy or
click the link in the QuickStart under
all web services then under App Engine
app you'll see the app you just deployed
select it on the right side panel click
add member add the email address of a
person or group and choose hi IP secured
web app user for role under cloud I a P
then save use the IEP slider next to the
App Engine app line to turn on IP for
this app that account will still see the
same welcome if logged in when browse a
another account we'll get an access
denied error as intended congratulations
your application is now protected by
identity where proxy and is only
accessible to the people you authorize
you